hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we will be reviewing
lifestyle youtuber marla catherine
okay but first let me tell you about my
sponsor lollipop
i've honestly never been a big soda
drinker
largely because i've got really super
sensitive teeth
and i really don't like the fuzzy
feeling i get when i have a really
sugary drink
i also can't drink diet pop anymore
because i just find the taste of
aspartame too cloyingly sweet
and now just like really distracting to
me but you guys know
i do love me my sparkling water because
i'm a fizzy
drink fiend and i do sometimes crave a
little more
flavor sweetness and fun in my drink
so i was definitely intrigued when i got
sent these lollipop sodas
especially because they come in really
fun
retro pop shop flavors like root beer
and cherry vanilla and orange squeeze
let's be real like
all of that totally reminds me of pool
parties
and slumber parties and simpler
times but these are a really fun option
if you do love
soda and you're looking for an
alternative without so much added sugar
or
aspartame or artificial colors or if you
just want to switch it up from your
general sparkling water lollipop also
contains
prebiotic fiber which is basically like
the food
that feeds the good bacteria in the gut
but just a quick note for folks with
really sensitive tummies
if you're not used to getting in a lot
of fiber you'll want to
slowly introduce it so it's not so much
fiber at once but if you want to try out
lollipop yourself
check out the link in my bio and use my
promo code abby sharp
for 15 off of the variety 12 pack
now you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating i also want to add that although
marla is technically an adult
she is only 18 years old so i always do
try to approach
this with additional sensitivity as
she's still in a very critical period of
growth and development
ultimately i know that i've got a lot of
teen and young adult followers so
for those of you in the age bracket i
want to make sure that you're getting
some good
evidence-based guidance based on the
influencers that you follow as well
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you never miss out on an
episode
all right so we're gonna be looking at
marla's most recent what i eat in a week
video at the time of filming
but as always since i am filming this in
advance
it may be not the most up-to-date
reflection of
marla's diet so bear with me let's take
a look no i really do have stomach
issues where i
first off i can't and i can't inhale i
can't consume too much dairy which i
feel like is a common one and then on
top of that if i eat
i feel like it's after six ish if i eat
any time after six
my stomach explodes and i get acid
reflex and i just
my stomach feels horrible for the rest
of the night okay so marla prefaces this
video by sharing that she experiences
some stomach issues including acid
reflux which i know
really sucks she specifically identifies
dairy as a possible culprit so she may
or may not be
lactose intolerant in this case in fact
dairy has been identified
as a very common trigger for acid reflux
particularly people who are intolerant
or who have gastroesophageal reflux
disease
aka gerd so if marla feels better by
cutting dairy from her diet
and she finds that her symptoms improve
then that is
probably a really good idea for her as
for her suggestion to avoid eating
anything
after 6 p.m i mean it is possible she
needs an
early cut off since it is usually
advised that you give yourself
up to three hours after eating before
laying down
to avoid acid reflux symptoms but unless
she goes to bed at like a geriatric hour
like me
[Music]
she might be able to push that out a bit
and even if she does find that she needs
like an earlier dinner
which is often advised most people with
gerd can tolerate a bedtime snack
made with non-triggering foods as for
said triggers
you know the most common culprits for
acid reflux are things like spicy or
fried foods
mint chocolate citrus foods alcohol
carbonated drinks and caffeine acid
reflux can also be caused by stress
eating a very large meal and lying down
immediately afterwards
or wearing really tight fitting clothing
around the waist
ironically acid reflux can also be
triggered
by waiting too long in between meals and
not eating enough food
the reason for this is that an empty
stomach is an acidic stomach
which can stimulate heartburn and
discomfort and then you're basically
adding insult to injury when you
introduce
things that can increase stomach acidity
like coffee
alcohol stress etc with all that said
let's talk about her
breakfasts so in this week i like that
marla enjoys a variety of different
breakfast options depending on
how she's feeling that day so whether
it's overnight oats
a chocolate protein shake or eggs we've
got a lot of really great
solid options to work with so let's take
a look at one example
okay definitely not like the most
aesthetically pleasing breakfast
i made like two eggs and then i got a
rice cake and then i put some peanut
butter honey and bananas on top i love
this breakfast because it's super
filling and it's really quick to make so
that's what i'm eating
today i love this super easy no fuss
breakfast and i like how she combined
a bit of savory from the egg with some
sweetness from the peanut butter rice
cake which is totally
my style when i cannot decide between
sweet or savory
so here we have some protein from the
eggs we've got
carbs from the banana and rice cake and
honey and some healthy fats and a bit
more protein from the peanut butter
now while i love that crunch from the
rice cake i totally get the texture
allure
rice cakes are pretty low carb and low
in fiber
so there's not a whole lot of nutrition
going on so i would personally choose a
heartier higher fiber bread like
sourdough
which not only would be arguably way
more delicious
but also more satiating as well she
could also throw in a bit of veg
into her eggs like some kale or spinach
or tomatoes which would definitely help
to
bump up the micronutrients flavor and
fiber as well
let's take a look at another example
i just did my smoothie and i feel like
i'm still hungry so this sounds good
right now i'm gonna eat this
clif bar and then go get ready for the
day okay so
i'm not so surprised that she needed the
clif bar after her smoothie
as there was not a ton going on there in
terms of
staying power while she is getting some
fiber and of course lots of
micronutrients from the berries
and the spinach there wasn't any
significant source of
protein or fats in there to help bump up
the satiety factor
for a more balanced smoothie that really
nails the hunger crushing combo
i would throw in a source of protein
like protein powder
soy milk instead of almond milk or
silken tofu
since she can't do dairy and i might add
in some healthy fats like nut butter
hemp hearts or flax as for the clif bar
these bars typically have a one to four
ratio of protein
to carbs making them ideal as a
post-workout snack as the higher amount
of carbs in the bar
are really great for replenishing those
energy stores while
also providing a little bit of protein
for muscle recovery
but if this wasn't a post-workout snack
i would probably suggest a higher
protein bar
since the smoothie was already pretty
carb heavy let's move on to snacks
okay so even though we saw some variety
with breakfast meals
marla is pretty loyal to her favorite
pretzel
and hummus combo when it comes to her
snacks
let's take a look i'm having like just a
little my afternoon snack before i make
my dinner later these are the
pretzel crisps this is the garlic
parmesan i think this is probably the
best flavor
with some garlic hummus that i stirred
up and then just some blackberries and
raspberries and
that is my snack for today okay so i am
officially craving those pretzel crisps
right now
and i've got to try the garlic parmesan
flavor sap
because i love anything pretzels also
hummus is inherently a pretty balanced
snack in there
because it's got the hunger crushing
combo of fiber protein
and fats already built in so if we
add those berries for the extra fiber
we've got pretzels for the crunch and
some carbs
i say we've got a pretty solid snack
looks great to me
and really delicious too now moving on
to marla's lunches
marla doesn't feature like a ton of
lunch options in this video
in fact we really only see two lunches
featured or mentioned
one of which is a taco that she says she
made but isn't
actually shown so it could be the case
that she just doesn't vlog them or
didn't vlog
them or that she possibly skips lunch
sometimes as she
did mention that she will do this if
she's not feeling particularly hungry
around lunchtime
now we're going to touch on this a bit
later on in the video but for now
let's take a look at one of the lunches
that she does eat in the week
okay guys amanda and i went and picked
up a salad we both
like are not able to finish one so we
just split one and then we got some
sweet potato fries
with the chipotle sauce okay so this
wild rice and kale salad looks
super yummy and i officially need it in
my life
so according to the cubby's website this
salad has wild rice
shredded kale slivered almonds avocado
apples dried cranberries
chicken goat's cheese and a balsamic
lemon cilantro vinaigrette
now there is literally nothing i don't
like about this as the flavor combo
sounds
totally on point this salad is also
super balanced
as we have some protein from the chicken
almonds and goat cheese
however depending on her sensitivity she
may need to sub out the goat's cheese
due to her
dairy intolerance but you know
everyone's different whether or not they
can
do cow's dairy versus goat's dairy etc
we also have some healthy fats from the
avocado and dressing
plus carbs from the wild rice apples and
cranberries
everything here to me is a solid 10.
and with a side of sweet potato fries
girl sign me up now the only concern
here is that because she's splitting the
meal with her friend
i would say that the portion size may be
a bit small
and while marla may be in tune with how
much he needs to eat to feel full
my main concern is her acid reflux later
on in the day
so i'm already seeing that her intake
drops around lunchtime
which could be what is setting her up to
experience a lot of discomfort later on
in the day
because as i already mentioned one
possible trigger of acid reflux is
actually not eating enough
food we also know that fried foods are
another common trigger so
while i am all for a little sweet potato
fry action in my life
it's just something to be mindful of if
you have severe symptoms
and you're unsure why having a larger
lunch would also mean potentially not
needing to have
a really really large dinner which again
would potentially help with that acid
reflux at night
and speaking of dinners let's move on to
see what she
has so with marla's dinners she will
either
do a bit of like meal prepping on her
own or with friends
or she'll enjoy a restaurant meal like
her favorite wild rice and kale salad
or a burger with fries so let's take a
closer look at some of her meal prep
this looks gorgeous stunning and sexy
okay guys
literally gorgeous sexy humble all of
the above it's a magician
i love these they're so filling too and
they're super easy to make it takes like
20 minutes max to make and
everyone in my family also loves them so
no food goes to waste and that's great
okay i have heard magical things about
these
pf chang chicken lettuce wraps that she
used for their recipe and they look
super easy and so flavorful i
too love using better lettuce as a wrap
especially in the summer months when
you get in a craving for something
refreshing that kind of crunch factor
but considering it's just chicken and a
little bit of water
chestnuts and there's no sides going on
it doesn't feel like
a lot of food even with that little like
two bite brownie in the mix still would
want more
especially since it seems like marla
completely skips lunch
or has a really small meal as well then
too
now marla does say that they're pretty
filling and they are rich in protein so
i am sure that definitely helps but i
would say that this would be
grossly insufficient for most young
women
i know i would probably need like at
least three wraps
plus a side of some rice or some carbs
in there
and also let's be real the dessert
so to make this a little bit more
balanced i would personally throw in
some more veggies maybe some celery
some bell peppers some carrots throw
them all into the stir fry there
and then of course i would serve it with
a source of carbs so
maybe some rice or some noodles and i
top the whole thing off
with some nuts like some cashews for a
nice crunch factor
and some healthy fats and yes i would
definitely
double down on those two by brownies
because those are life
but i would say that one of these little
wraps would be
grossly inefficient for most young women
like i would definitely need three or
four of those plus size
now of course marla could very well have
like a small appetite
and feel really good eating smaller
portions but my concern
here is the frequency of these small
portions
and the 6 pm cut off time for food by
implementing an arbitrary rule around
when she needs to stop eating to prevent
stomach pain in combination with these
super small meals throughout the day she
may actually be doing herself a
disservice and making her acid reflux
worse if she were my client i would
definitely want to experiment with
having more
energy dense meals and snacks to see if
having
more food on board would actually help
to reduce
her symptoms so now let's get to the
stats
and again the trigger warning that i am
going to be talking about numbers so
feel free to skip ahead
to the timestamp on screen so after
crunching
the numbers on average marla is
consuming around 850 calories a day
which goes up slightly to around 1200
calories on
days when she goes out to eat with her
friends she's also consuming a pretty
low carb diet with around
42 of her calories from carbs 16
from protein and 41 from fat now with
that said
her caloric intake is definitely very
low
for someone marla's age especially
considering that she
is still you know in her young adulthood
years
and requires more calories to support
growth and development
typically the average active girl around
her age
would require around 2000 to 2400
calories a day
which is actually more than what the
average adult woman needs
so this means that based on what we are
seeing here
in this week marla is getting less than
half of her energy needs
and that's a serious issue also because
she's just generally not eating enough
food
she's also critically low on a bunch of
micronutrients as well
particularly those that are important
for teens and young adults for growth so
things like
calcium vitamin d potassium zinc and
iron now before we talk
further about this let's discuss what i
like about marla's diet first of all i
like that marla has some
good variety in her meals and aside from
not eating dairy
she doesn't appear to eliminate any
major food groups or
types of foods some days she'll eat a
salad for lunch
while others she's gonna open the
burgers and fries
so it's really great to see this type of
flexibility in her food choices
and that she isn't purposefully aiming
to eat clean
or super healthy foods 100 of the time
i also like that even though she knows
what she loves
and she sticks to that like her hummus
and pretzel combo
or the wild rice and kale salad for
example she also isn't afraid to try new
things
like the viral tik tok pesto eggs recipe
that i've
actually also been meaning to try myself
so it's really great to see
that she's got a really good open mind
about food lastly
i always appreciate any youtuber who
doesn't use the typical
deity verbiage that i am so used to
hearing in my reviews
so i'm happy to say that my diet culture
bingo card is
pretty empty pretty sparse when it comes
to marla
and for that of course she gets an extra
gold star so now let's talk about some
gentle nutrition tips as i mentioned
earlier
marla could certainly benefit from
having more energy dense meals and
snacks
throughout the day while also
prioritizing a lunch meal
not only would this help to possibly
prevent her acid reflux symptoms but it
would also ensure that she's meeting her
daily energy needs
now unless marla is eating more food
off-camera
i would be worried about the lack of
nutrition in her days
which of course has implications for
growth and development
so for example research has shown that
under eating
in adolescence and young adulthood can
significantly increase the risk of iron
deficiency
irregular periods and osteoporosis and
considering that marla is eliminating
dairy from an already very low calorie
diet
it's very likely that she's just not
getting enough calcium
or vitamin d which can further impact
her bone health
and based on our calculations she's only
meeting between
13 and 39 of her calcium needs depending
on the day
so this is definitely one major area for
improvement with that said some
non-dairy sources of calcium that she
could begin to implement into her diet
include things like calcium set tofu
canned salmon
beans and lentils almonds dark leafy
greens
as well as fortified plant-based milks
juices and cereals
now it's a bit unclear as to why her
lunch meal is
often skipped according to this video at
least
she either isn't hungry when the lunch
time kind of rolls around
or she's too busy to eat now while it's
certainly
not optimal it's not uncommon to see a
lot of teens and young adults
skip meals or like graze their way
through the day
and grazing is fine as long as you're
still meeting your nutrient needs but in
marla's case
i would strongly suggest trying to make
that lunch meal
more of a priority so some strategies
for this might include having
leftovers from dinner the night before
or doing a bit more meal prep earlier in
the week so that she can have something
at the ready when life gets super busy
now on days when she's not super hungry
around lunchtime
or maybe she can't stomach a really
large meal
she could opt for easy snack-like meals
that are balanced with the hunger
crushing combo so
some examples are like some whole grain
crackers with a pouch of
tuna and some kind of veggies or maybe
an apple or banana
with lots of nut butter and a few
handfuls of trail mix
otherwise she could also go for the
chocolate protein shake and maybe
adding in like a piece of fruit that she
usually has for breakfast
as liquid calories may be an easier way
for her to get her energy needs up
if she doesn't have a huge appetite for
a meal these still would be what i
consider small meals but
somewhere to start if she's really just
not used to having a
solid sized meal now to help her with
her acid reflux
rather than live by the no food after 6
p.m rule
i would modify this to just try to avoid
eating three hours before bedtime
as lying down too soon after eating can
cause those stomach acids to rise up
and cause heartburn so if marla
typically goes to bed at 9pm and she's
very sensitive
then it's possible that her 6 pm rule
might apply
however if it's possible she could
experiment with
a more easily digestible snack before
bed
like a banana based protein smoothie
that would be a really good one
and i would really just try to recommend
that she's trying to eat a meal or snack
every two to three hours while also
being mindful of the specific
foods and beverages mentioned earlier
that could potentially trigger her
symptoms
in the event that she does experience
some acid reflex
some foods that may help to prevent or
relieve symptoms
include things like ginger oatmeal
bananas
and other non-acidic fruits lean meats
seafoods
veggies and healthy fats basically if
she were my client
i would strongly recommend experimenting
to see if there are ways to get
more food in without triggering symptoms
as for marla's relationship with food it
is a bit difficult to assess
whether or not she's purposefully
restricting her food
she simply has like a low appetite due
to her reflex
is forgetting to eat or she is in fact
meeting her caloric needs off camera
and eating more than what she shows
there's really no
way for me to know what her actual
intake is versus
what she's sharing with the world and
honestly i'm not here to diagnose anyone
or suggest that marla is struggling with
her relationship with food but what i
can say is that the amount of calories
shown in this video are dangerously low
for someone of her age
and are cause for concern when it comes
to healthy growth and development
in addition to the insufficient amount
of calories consumed
the small portions skipping lunch and
the shortened eating window
are not really indicative of a healthy
relationship with food
and are also common red flags for
disordered eating
especially if we're seeing this every
single day of the week
now marla does identify herself as an
intuitive eater because
she eats when she's hungry and while
eating when you're hungry and stopping
when you're full is a great way to
approach your meals
and begin to hone in on your intuitive
eating skills my concern
is around marla's pattern and frequency
of eating
it might feel intuitive to have a small
lunch if you've had a
larger breakfast or to maybe delay your
usual lunch time by a few hours
if you're not feeling hungry around noon
this is all
quite normal and intuitive however
repeatedly skipping
lunch is not and is physiologically
inconsistent with marla's energy needs
and while i'd want to trust that marla
is in tune with her hunger and satiety
signals
and gives her body what it needs i don't
want viewers at home
watching this thinking that you can just
skip meals or under eat in the name of
intuitive eating
in fact when your hunger drive is so low
that it leads you to miss out on half of
your energy and nutrient needs for the
day
there's a good chance that those cues
cannot actually be trusted this is why
we don't just have people
jump into intuitive eating or listening
to their body
when they've been suffering from an
eating disorder there are a lot of wires
that
need to be uncrossed first so in order
to get her hunger and fullness signals
back to where they need to be marla may
need to approach
her meals with more structure through
what we would call
mechanical eating which is essentially
eating
in the absence of hunger cues and it's
more like
a little bit of a meal plan so this
would mean
eating a balanced breakfast lunch and
dinner with snacks in between
ideally with some guidance from a
registered dietitian
we often like to think of mechanical
eating as kind of like the cast
that we need to put on our broken hunger
cues
before we can start to trust them on
their own again
but essentially this process helps
gradually restore appetite
to better support energy and nutrition
needs so that you can get to a place
where you
can trust your intuition and true hunger
and on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today but thank you again to ollie pop
for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it a
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what you would like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye